155 billion euros that's amount  committed for the 2016 EU budget and  unlike previous years there was none of  the usual infighting amongst  institutions Donna Lucianna unanimity  Silla premiere fois cosa r EV I'm a  significant redirection of funds is for  the refugee crisis una Doble wanna video  media yoho-o combat her like he's on a  cap remilia-san possible after mom all  that work but this is a budget that  wants to concentrate on growth it makes  up nearly half the budget provision some  sixty nine point eight billion euros  horizon 2020 the EU primary research and  development program is getting 10  billion euros over eleven percent more  than the previous year schulich quacky  did I pitampura / tomorrow about Russia  an initiative risky obey me if one day  my honest is a professor a free delivery  shahbaz covers a global mafia so over to  the vote at the plenary would it be as  plain sailing face a second difficulty  le beyond agua de la serenity budget